that's my sube she is always trying to
stay a step ahead of the competition
she runs a successful online shop called
darling which sells fashion accessories
if you buy 10,000 I am be back of course
you are very picky we do have these kind
of bets here and if you buy 100 I am be
back then you couldn't be very tolerant
with the small mistakes so we always
give the price with the products and
then we were thinking whether it is
acceptable or not it's just another
hectic business day in Beijing for me
and this moment to what keeping keeps me
here is more the speech in Germany is a
very precise there are not a lot of
mistakes but it's a relatively slow pace
there are a lot of analysis evaluation
after a decision is done but in China we
have many many more mistakes that's
really the headache you very often find
mistakes upstairs but we our execution
speed is really fast when one topic is
discussed today and tomorrow we already
have the plan and the next week the
products are already online there's
always something new on offer and Hubei
C's team just keeps growing she says
most of her customers make purchases
over their smartphones but she's
unwilling to reveal exact sales figures
like many young Chinese entrepreneurs
Hugh studied abroad before returning
home she likes Beijing in spite of the
smog
originally from Shanghai to Beijing
studied and worked in France and Germany
but here in Beijing her life is more
fast-paced so she couldn't do without
household help
she was cooked serves up her favorite
dish right on schedule for this
businesswoman even relaxation is serious
business work hard play hard it's like
for my younger age now it's more like
work hard
relax hard here in China the work life
is intensive and it's not only you it's
for every surface industry you know the
work life is intensive so then that
means we can also benefit from the hard
working of the others surface industry
she heads out of Beijing passing the
headquarters of China Central Television
she was always reachable increasingly
Chinese consumers are issuing brand-name
goods in favor of more individual
lifestyle products at darling storage
Depot they're taking inventory while
over capacities are often an issue in
Germany in China
Hubei she can barely keep up with the
demand what isn't selling is given an
extra push if the nice item doesn't go
very well it will go down with the
ranking and the lower ranking you have
the lower chance you will be on top of
the page so the hot selling position you
will not get them because there is an
automatic calculation so after today
give our buyers see these items still
have the potential to sell then they
will manually change the ranking to say
go up of these items so then we could
push the item on good selling position
with the same price shoe belongs to
what's being called the gold collar
generation young and influential
businesspeople
at night she works out in the gym of a
luxury hotel in Beijing the ability to
combine their professional and private
lives is increasingly important to
China's business people I never would
say that I will stay here forever I
think maybe whether it's a 40 years old
or 50 years old I even probably could be
35 years old and I feel it here is the
too noisy I don't like Lee speed I want
to be more relaxed have better leisure
time I probably will move back to Europe
it's all possible for now that 29 year
old enjoys her few free moments hubei
she often falls asleep during her
midnight massage and awakens raring to
go once again